in continuous random variables we've
been looking at variants right now and I
presented these two definitions there's
two different ways of calculating
variance there's this guy over here
which is kind of like via the definition
if you like of what variance is we're
taking our difference between each score
and the mean we square it because we're
interested in the the difference you
know irrespective of which direction
it's the difference like is it above the
mean is a below don't really care I just
care about how far away it is and then
multiplied by the probability of that
difference happening so this is kind of
like our definition for variance but
then we kind of provided this
alternative version because we said and
I gave an example this which I'll come
back to you later and when you try
evaluating this integral it's often a
bit of a mess and so we basically said
that for practical purposes we really
use this particular definition when we
have a uniform distribution whereas for
more or less anything else we go with
this guy over here if you have a
non-uniform probability distribution
this right-hand definition for variance
turns out to be much more useful but
what we didn't really have time to go
into is well how do you convince
yourself that these two actually are the
same thing like why should they give you
the variance I'm using both formulas
okay so that's what we're going to do
right now we're going to prove that from
that first initial definition using some
some knowledge of calculus a bit of
algebra and also some of the
particularity of probability density
functions we can take all that knowledge
together and prove that we can get from
one definition to the other so let's
have a go at that we're going to start
over here on the left hand definition
and what I want to do with this is when
I think about how to work with this
thing the X minus mu all squared there's
the the mean right in there mu for mean
I want to be able to start integrating
this but because it's kind of squared at
the moment it's difficult for me to see
ten by ten what's going on so the first
thing I'm going to do inside the
integral is I'm going to expand that X
minus mu so we get x squared we're going
to subtract double the product of those
two terms inside there that by
and then we're going to add the square
of the second one so there's my X minus
mu all squared I've just expanded it
it's of course multiplied by f of X our
probability density function and we're
integrating with respect to X now to
start to get to this thing over here on
the right hand side you can always start
to see oh I'm already headed in the
right direction for starters if you have
a look at this first term here right
you've got this x squared when you
factor expand it out not factorize it's
already factorize when you expand it out
that x squared is going to multiply by f
of X and you're integrating well you can
see that that's what you get over here
that's this term that's the first piece
so somehow we've got to show that all
the rest of the pieces here once we sort
of expand them out and try and use some
of our knowledge to simplify them we
should somehow end up on just minus mu
squared so how do we get there well what
I'm going to do is I'm going to separate
out these terms into three different
integrals so the first one is the one I
just highlighted in red underline it's
from A to B x squared f of X DX so you
can see what I'm doing is I'm kind of
multiplying this guy across and then I
treat it as its own integral right now
let's have a look at the next one so
I'll color B's just so it's a bit more
easy to follow um this guy in here
what's that going to give me so I'm
going to subtract the integral from A to
B of 2 mu X and then I'm multiplying
again by this f of X I'm gonna stop
continue to write that because I have
too many arrows and you can see I'm
multiplying by f of X every time so
there comes f of X DX so there's the
final the second rather integral and
then what we got in here so there's that
mu squared so I'll stay with blue so
I've got plus the integral from A to B
of MU squared f of X DX okay so
hopefully you're following so far all
I've done here is I've split apart that
one big integral which we got from the
definition for variance and I've broken
it into its component pieces okay now
how do I progress well like we saw
before this guy here I that in my second
definition
for various so I didn't need to change
that guy it's kind of ready to go as it
is so then I had to think about well
what about the rest of these pieces so
just to help us keep it all separate I'm
going to keep using the colors that I've
used above when you have a look at this
second integral in here what I notice is
you've got this two and this new both of
which are just numbers right like mu
which is the expected value or the mean
after I go through the whole process for
my particular probability density
function eventually I get a number out
right so if two and mu are just numbers
there are constant coefficients that I
can factorize out just like anything
else so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to have that minus sign there and
I'm going to factorize out two and mu
and then the rest of the integral
follows so I get X f of X DX okay so
there's that middle one and then I come
over to this last one here and in
exactly the same way that two and mu are
a constant they're just the number the
MU squared that you can see right here
that's also just the number I'm part of
what's hard about recognizing that is
there's just so much algebra everywhere
in fact the only numbers you can see
other twos here here and here
everything else is a premium rule and so
you kind of have to hone your ability to
recognize which pronumerals are
constants therefore they can be
factorized out and which ones of them
are variables and so they affect the
integration so you can't just take them
out as factors so U squared is one of
those things that I can take out so I'm
gonna factorize out the Mew squared and
then I get left with the rest of the
integral which is just the f of X DX
okay now maybe as you see these terms
your brain is starting to take over
right this first one here I'm just gonna
leave it because it's gonna be part of
my final thing and when you have a look
at this guy here I want you to focus in
on just this one part of the expression
this part in here that's like that in
let's get the color looking right so it
doesn't look so distracting okay now
when you have a look at this guy here I
wonder if you recognize what the
integral from A to B of X f of X is
think about what's going on here right
what you're doing is you're taking each
score and then you're multiplying by its
probability
we've done this calculation recently
right this is how we work out the
expected value it's every score
multiplied by how likely you are to get
that score so since it's the expected
value it's also the mean which is me
right so therefore I can write this as
minus 2 mu that whole integral just
becomes mu again right so 2 mu x mirror
I'll simplify that on the next line when
you have a look over here again I'm
gonna ask you to focus on the integral
so let's uh let's highlight it with blue
this time cuz that's the color of this
guy and term we'll do the same thing
make it look a little more consistent
there we go now when you have a look at
this integral I hope it's even easier to
recognize this is the integral over the
entire domain from A to B of your
function that's all the probabilities
are being added up so therefore if
you're adding up all the probabilities
then this entire integral should just
give you one because it's a probability
density function so what I can say here
is you've got that mu squared that's
outside of the integral and then the
integral itself which just gives you one
so now I think that it's sufficiently
simple I'm just going to write this all
in a single color next I think you can
follow along this first term here that
integral is just going to stay put
I've got minus 2 mu squared plus a
single mu square so I can just collect
like terms over here on the right hand
side one more time this integral is just
gonna stay where it is and then I get
minus well 2 mu squared plus 1 mu
squared is just gonna leave me with
minus mu squared and that's the result
we were having a look at hopefully you
recognize that from up the top here
right there this is the result we were
hoping to prove so there's not as many
lines but you really have to think
carefully and there's just there's just
so much algebra here that it's easy to
get lost
to be honest especially when these terms
are unfamiliar with us now the last
thing that it's worth a mentioning is
that this is us showing how the two
formulas for variance they really are
the same just to convince yourself so
you don't have to just accept because
someone tells you that they are the same
but I just want to make some final notes
on notation so if you have a look here
this is what I've been calculating here
is variance right and one of the things
that you can see
the original definition for variance
this guy up here is that we state that
in terms of this integral right so I'm
going to write it over here
the integral from A to B of X minus mu
all squared times your probability f of
X DX okay that's what's equal to this
okay now it's worth noting that you know
this mu that we use for instead of
expected value and we use it instead of
writing e of x because it is ever so
slightly more succinct especially
because you've got lots of them flying
around so it's just easier to write mu
especially when you're multiplying and
collecting like terms and all the rest
but I want you to remember that the
expected value is by definition it's the
integral from A to B of X f of X and the
thing is that the expected value of x it
sort of goes into this X that you can
see out the front the expected value of
that score is the score times the
probabilities okay now what that means
is whatever is in here and in here ends
up being equivalent and you can actually
see that in these other two integrals
that you have over here on the left hand
side it's just that we don't have X
inside the integral we've got these
other things so for example let's go
with this one in here you don't have an
X you have an x squared so therefore we
can rewrite this integral here as not an
integral as an expected value except
it's not the expected value of x it's
the expected value of all right at color
so you can see it it's the expected
value of x squared and I'm getting that
from this guy here okay you can see on
the left hand side you've got this other
integral over here let's put it in a
purple water so I've got the x minus mu
or squared in there instead of just an X
so therefore this guy on the Left can
also be written as an expected value
it's the expected value of what you can
see in purple so it's X minus mu or
squared okay so that's a different
expected value and then you've got this
minus mu squared on the end which we
could just as easily have
written as I'll put in a lighter color
so in confuse er this we could have
written as the expected value sometimes
they just put that square right on the
end there
okay so what's sort of appealing about
this way you can see it written down
here is you can state the entire thing
as a relationship between a bunch of
different expected values and the reason
why this guy in here which I'll just
highlight our one last time in one big
box this guy here is where I wanted to
end is because this is the result that
gets given to you on your reference
sheet so if you have a look at the
statistics section it's on the second
page that here's page 1 here's page 2
when you go over to statistical analysis
just underneath this section that talks
about the normal distribution you've got
these symbols in here right so you've
got expected value equals mu so that's
the expected value and mean are the same
thing and then you've got this
expression in here I'm just going to put
these side-by-side so you can see them
variance here on the right hand side
variance equals and then you can see
expected value of X minus mu all squared
so that's what I wrote here equals the
expected value of x squared minus mu
squared so this result here is the one
which we want you to be able to refer to
but you can see what's underneath it is
this series of integrals it's really
calculus which helps us interpret like
where these results come from and why
they're true so I hope you find that
helpful and that it convinces you and
why we can use these results not just
you know that they're true but you know
the reason that they're true